all right so a couple of days ago I
posted a video explaining Amazon's
hiring freeze long story short Amazon
isn't planning to hire any more people
until 2023. there are some exceptions to
this for example if someone leaves the
company or moves on to another role they
may need to hire a backfield to replace
them but essentially hiring at Amazon
and AWS is frozen if you're someone
looking to land a job in the cloud
industry this is probably not the news
you want to hear ever since the start of
the pandemic AWS has hired so many
solutions Architects Cloud Engineers
Cloud Architects and software Engineers
things were pretty good for job Seekers
because there was a huge demand for
people with Cloud skills through this
YouTube channel and one-on-one mentoring
I was able to help dozens of people land
jobs at AWS this year but with the
current economic situation Amazon along
with many other tech companies had to
implement a hiring freeze this video is
dedicated to my amazing subscribers who
have spent the past few weeks and months
building up their technical skills in
order to land a job in the cloud and
industry I know the job market isn't
looking too great right now but I want
to share with you where you can find
high paying Cloud jobs during the hiring
freeze and here's the secret you don't
necessarily have to work at AWS to work
in an AWS Cloud job let me say that
again you don't have to work at the
Amazon web services company to work in a
role where you get to use AWS
Technologies to help customers in fact
AWS has a massive partner network of
over a hundred thousand Partners from
more than 150 countries and many of
these partner companies are looking for
people to work in their Cloud teams some
of you might already know this but this
is something I've never had to share on
this channel because there was always so
many open positions within AWS and so in
this video I'm going to be sharing how
to find AWS jobs that are outside of the
Amazon web services company and more
broadly how to find out which tech
companies are actually hiring before we
get into how to find those jobs I like
to mention that this video is in
collaboration with school up now more
than ever it's important for you to
continue building your skills to stand
out in the job market screw up is a
learning platform by simply learn and
then now offer over 200 free courses to
help you gain in-demand technical skills
which could help you get high paying
jobs the courses are self-paced and
available from both your browser and
their mobile app meaning you can learn
anywhere at any time you want the video
lessons are prepared by industry experts
and aims to help fast track your
learning as you can see here they have a
few introduction to AWS courses that are
completely free of cost the best part is
you can complete the courses in just a
few hours and what's pretty cool is at
the end of each course you'll be awarded
with a certificate of completion these
certificates can then help validate your
skill set in AWS and other Technologies
so to start learning with screw up check
out the link in the video description
below that directs to the sign up page
now let's get back to the video okay so
how do you find AWS jobs that are
outside of the AWS company let me
introduce you to Sally Sally has just
passed the AWS Solutions Arctic
associate exam last month and has built
two AWS Cloud projects she's now ready
to start applying to jobs and her dream
job is to either become an AWS Cloud
engineer or any previous devops engineer
but she finds out that Amazon has just
announced a hiring phrase and thinks to
herself is a game over then do I still
have a chance of Landing a job in the
cloud here's what I'd recommend to Sally
first head to
partners.amazonaws.com then enter your
location for example Australia here you
can see a whole list of companies in
your country that AWS has partnered up
with to help customers build Cloud
Solutions on AWS not all of these
companies might be hiring but I
recommend taking a look at the job
portals to see if there's a role you
might be interested in if Sally finds
this too time consuming and doesn't want
to look at each job portal one by one
she can go onto a job search website
like indeed by searching AWS associate
she'll be able to find associate level
jobs that are looking for people with
AWS Cloud skills for example let's take
a look at this associate devops engineer
role they are looking to hire someone
with a practitioner level AWS or Azure
certification and or a degree with a
focus on software engineering slash
development Sally has two AWS
certifications so this shouldn't be an
issue they they mentioned they don't
need an expert but they want someone
interested in Cloud infrastructure and
has a fundamental knowledge of public
Cloud Concepts and also basic
programming and scripting experience and
that's a great example of how to find an
AWS job that's outside of the AWS
company with the Amazon hiring freeze
going on roles in the company will be
limited so this strategy will really
help you find jobs that are outside of
AWS where you still get to use your
Cloud skills for those watching who are
open to exploring positions outside of
cloud computing there's actually a
website that lists out the companies
still looking to hire people if you head
to levels.fyi forward slash still hiring
you'll see a list of companies and the
types of jobs they're hiring for you can
filter by role for example if you select
devops you can see which companies are
looking for devops engineers it seems
like there's a bunch of remote positions
available as well so if you want the
flexibility to work from home take a
look at the companies that offer remote
work one bonus tip is to make sure you
turn your resume to each position you
apply for I know at this point it might
be tempting to just submit your resume
to to every single job opening you see
but because there are less open roles
available it's important to make sure
you can stand out in the application
process this means making sure your
resume is up to date with your work
experience certifications education and
projects but also instead of just
dumping everything onto one or two pages
make sure you pick the relevant
experiences and skills that best align
with the job description if you're
someone looking to land a job in Tech
please leave a comment below and I'd
love to get back to you with some
tailored advice and as always please
give this video a like if you found it
helpful and I'll see you soon bye for
now